the question i want to know is
what gave birth to the al qaeda movement
okay that that's what i want to know
what was the rage what was the incident
what was the event
what was the hatred for western
civilization
i have my idea where i want to go with
this but i kind of want to hear it from
you to see
what you think caused this rage uh
that led to the al qaeda movement
well first of all i'm sure you're
familiar with this term in islam which
is
kaffir right the infidels
you know um
when the soviets invaded afghanistan
in 79
for people like osama bin laden
who are proponents of jihad
and truly believe in the expansion of
the religion as it's stated in the in
the books
having you know infidels and non-believe
especially non-believers you know that
you know communists are viewed even
worse
as christians or jewish because they
have their atheists
so having you know these people try to
invade a muslim territory
was something that was you know
had to be fought on head-on and so
what happened was that osama bin laden
set up actually a sort of infrastructure
you know
where he gathered you know funding um he
built the army the muhajradin um
and then more minor things like
collecting you know goods and supplies
to bring over there
in order to go fight and from
the stories that my mother tells me he
was very admired
in saudi arabia for um
[Music]
setting up all of this and going ahead
and actually going to defend
you know their brothers in in
afghanistan so
that was kind of the birth of when
osama bin laden who was this very pious
devout muslim
then became a leader
in the sense that he was going to be
this fighter for
their ideology and you can see you know
throughout the 80s that
they went they fought in afghanistan and
then he created
mac which was the precursor to
al-qaeda if i'm not mistaken in 1984
and then it subsequently became
al-qaeda and
[Music]
it became their it became their mission
to
[Music]
to defend afghanistan but then also to
expand
expand islam because this is what they
feel they're called to do
so yeah i mean they are
they they're they're at a whole
different level and that's uh
uh uh the the kefir infidels rejecting
of the religion of muslim that i don't
want to accept this religion it's a
it's a big insult to them but the part
where i was going with this
is can i can i interject just one thing
maybe for your viewers
most will maybe know this but i think
people
here in the west have a
limited understanding of what islam is
because of the media and what they're
being told you know they
in a very reductive manner say that
islam is a religion
but it's incomplete to call islam a
religion which is why i always say it's
an ideology because
although there is a religious component
to islam
there are two key additional elements
which is you know the military
doctrine as well as the political agenda
and this forms
the whole of um of the ideology that
is islam and those who believe
and again there's a spectrum of muslims
in terms of how they approach islam and
how they apply it
but those who who
apply a literal literal tran
literal application of islam are these
jihadists and not only you know
jihadists
in the physical sense but you know all
those who also aid and abet
the jihadists whether by financial means
whether by infrastructure
you know back coming back to europe and
the united states
you know organizations which are fronts
for the muslim brotherhood for instance
that
base their operations here in order to
spread the ideology
through more subversive means
rather than those horrible blatant
attacks that have been happening you
know in our streets
let me ask you one thing that's very
helpful to say that from what you know
al qaeda what year did al qaeda go okay
in 1988 to present
so uh uh in in osama bin laden he was
born do you know what year your uncle
was born i'm just curious to know what
yuri was born
let me take a look at this what year
this man was born because i knew your
father's older 1957. okay
1957 1977 okay so that'd be 20 years
so in in 19 in the mid 70s iran
the middle east was pretty peaceful
there was not a lot of issues going on
the middle east and obviously shaw was
the one running the middle east he was
the most powerful man he had all the
contracts back
he took oil back from uk with you know
the whole thing that was going on and
you know he was starting you know by
weapon and they were becoming stronger
and gradually growing and
he had three thousand political
prisoners in that group of political
prisoners that he had he had a lot of
the current
not the current the leaders that ended
up starting al qaeda
and jimmy carter came out with this
campaign of human rights
asking him to release the political
prisoners and many of those political
prisoners who were released
are the ones that ended up going and
leaving because there were extremists in
his eyes
some of them were too day which you know
i don't know if you're familiar with
today two days the communists back in
the days
that were coming down from russia and
the whole karl marx movement was growing
in iran and he wanted to put that down
but slowed that down no problem but then
the other part was he had some of these
extreme extreme jihadists
you know the folks that ended up
building al qaeda that he knew
were problematic and once he released
them
next thing you know we know what
happened to everything else and that
leads to obviously al-qaeda getting
started in 1988 and that leads to
al qaeda you know osama bin laden
attacked out on 19 you know
9 11. but i'm asking that question
because for me a lot of times i want to
know why you hate i want to know
why a certain sect or why a certain
community hates another community what
caused you to get to that point
what happened with that and uh there are
many different stories
in uh in this section on why that
happened do you have any final thoughts
on this before we move on to the next
topic
i think it's um it's interesting that
you that you bring up
um iran and actually i encourage
all your viewers to watch your video
that you did uh
explaining uh what's going on in iran
you know it's a 30 minute video you did
that explains the
relationship between the west and and
iran which was great
um many of the things my mother had told
me about you know including the today
party and then um
how they aided you know in homini's
return and all of that
and sadly um
the taking of power by you know
extremists in iran in 79
when you look at images maybe your
viewers don't know that but both my
grandmothers are actually
um iranian you know but when you look at
the middle east you know in the 70s
and you see these women in iran who were
liberated
and as you mentioned in the video you
know they had the right to vote and they
had to right to go to university they
had the right to become judges
and you know boom 79 happens and it's a
complete
reversal uh
of all this this progress
um and the situation
of women in uh in iran was completely
turned upside down and
it makes me really sad when i when i
follow what's going on in
iran today and you know women are being
jailed
for removing their head scarf and you
know these are all stories you know that
my mother lived as well
i think you were maybe you were too
young um
yourself but my mother you know saul of
this
you know you know happened she was at
the heart of it you know in the 70s and
the early
early 80s but um as you say you know
people should research all of these
things you know all these feminists
today in the west
think you know there's uh oppression
and inequality and um i i really want to
tell them you know go
find out about other places in the world
and what's happening today
you know in places like iran and um
and fight for these women you know fight
for these women who don't have a voice
who have
who are forced and obliged to wear the
veil which
i i i really don't
i can't stand the veil you know and then
you have here in the west you know
mattel coming out with the veiled barbie
and
nike coming out with nike coming out
with them
hijab with a swoosh and and knowing you
know
what's happening in uh in the middle
east and
and these women who are being persecuted
it's just
things are upside down patrick i agree
with you
i would i would challenge any journalist
who's a
firm believer being a who's a feminist
to go to iran
not for one week to just make a show and
show how amazing it is and how much love
there is there
but go to iran and work there for two
years and try to advance and see what
happens for you and
i'd encourage you do that to do that and
realize that nowadays
yeah a 13 year old girl can get married
today
uh and the 13 year old girl to get
married
to a 40 year old man or 30 year old man
is a normal thing in iran and
if you think that's christian um
christian amanpour should do what you
just said
and you know she's busy cozying up with
all the
the religious leaders of iran and at the
same time
castigating all all of us trump
supporters
um and comparing us to to nazis
comparing
um the president and our movement to
kristallnacht like three four days ago i
don't know if you saw that clip
and she should go and and uh if she
doesn't like it here in the west why
doesn't she go
and live there it's so grapes and
there's a big list of them that i'd love
for them to go there for me i'm
i'm my biggest thing is i'm here because
i support capitalism i want freedom i
want you to leave me alone don't bother
me let me get to work if i break
a a law and you want to do something
fine totally get it but all the rest of
them leave
leave the creators and everybody else
along and give them a voice versus
what's going on right now with
censorship but we'll get to censorship
here in a minute
you